this is completely off topic uh I don't
think I've ever asked you this were you
a theater kid in in school yes I was bro
here's the ultimate I I was just I was
just like I just wanted to confirm
because I just assumed you were I
figured that out first five minutes of
meeting okay okay I was also a a theater
major in college so I doubled down into
debt um but so I think as long as I can
remember performance or theater but
theater kid seems to be more of an
insult these days I've noticed it's like
kind of I think it just means more
expressive it depends on the person I
think us it's the energy you know it's
the energy of just not not exactly like
wanting to be the center of attention
but just wanting to go out there and
express themselves you may that's true
yeah but yeah it's it ain't nothing
wrong with that a nothing wrong that but
I I notic just it's just a unique energy
you know I think it's like people who
are like willing to throw themselves
into a moment for like for like whatever
purpose like in joke with your friends
or if it's performance or whatever is
that a kid considered an insult I think
now I think now it depends in the like
let's go back to 25 years ago right when
I was around high school and stuff you
had jocks you had band kids you had
choir kids you had like choir kids yeah
like the ones who sing a lot you know
those nerds but like you know no I'm kid
I'm kidding I was in choir but they
kicked me out but like but theater kid
wasn't really an established tropy
actually before before you get further I
just everything you just named out
sounds like a typical American scho
movie I wanted to I I want to ask how
accurate are American High School movies
cuz I remember like when I first started
dating Sydney I was like oh was your
school like this was the Dynamics like
this and and her school was like no it
was like nothing like that was your
school think so before I answer the
question I am very curious on to see
what is your imagination can you tell me
what is your expectation of an American
High School kids getting pushed into the
lockers lockers yeah kids getting push
in lockers uh the jocks uh basically
every mid 2000s American High School
letter jacket jackets jocks are always
dating one of the cheerleaders there's
there's the girl that's not like other
girls that everyone secretly crushes
over everyone drives to school ohone
drives to school everyone bullies all
the AV club kids oh certainly I was
Captain of
that but that's and debate so I was like
I was really I was I was down basically
if you distilled mean girls into reality
that's like what I imagined it would be
I would say from when I went to high
school Embrace yourselves from 98 to
2002 there was a very strong semblance
of these kind of broad Strokes of
personalities it was very clicky is
really what it was so jocks or or sports
related people didn't usually cross over
into theater were they the cool kids
were they the cool kids I would say that
to put it into context um somehow I won
prom King my senior year this was an
unprecedented feat in this sense before
me the previous 19 winners had been
Sports captains right and so I think you
broke the meta man I broke the meta by
Thug intimidation and like rigging the
votes but like no but like for a really
long time your your Val victorians or
your your most popular kids would be
sports stars or the captain of the
basketball football wrestling team
always show out to me when I was
watching American uh school stuff and I
guess even when I see pictures of it now
I'm like huh we have like way less stuff
in British schools we just don't have a
lot of things it seem like the
facilities were really good in American
schools like they like the idea of
having lockers I was like that's you
guys didn't have lockers no you don't
get a locker I thought everything was
like Potter you had common room no you
don't get lockers you get lockers in
your school right I don't think we did
no we didn't have lockers we had lockers
but they weren't like the huge American
crazy you get a locker like that's why
you would allow up BR a bag and you just
lug it around all day no no no we
because the most valuable time was the
like 5 to 10 minutes between Class we'd
go to your locker and hang out and like
you'd have like the full Suite of
whatever you know we didn't really get
time in between classes you usually just
go right to the next one what goes in a
locker well you got your bags that's
most
important girls had like mirrors and
makeup and like all kinds of different
things that they could you know address
and do stuff uh I kept comic books Game
Boy materials uh you know trading cards
you know things that were more relevant
to someone my age in the '90s and then I
guess nowaday I can just I I I'm like
imagining just your character archetype
in every like high school movie now man
yeah I was the kid pushed into the
locker and I'd be like I'm going to get
you I I also saw this new school in
Texas it was like I don't know if you
can get a picture of it there was this
like super school being built in Texas
okay and the cafeteria was just all fast
food chains oh we that the thought of
having a fast food chain in the school
blows my mind uh I don't know if I could
oh it's like a yeah fast food CH there
was like this yeah look at this yeah
yeah click that one click that one wait
that's a mall this is this is a high
school high school in Texas it has Sonic
uh uh Jimmy John
piz isn't this insane not even how uni
had this I think I think genuinely
happened in the UK there'd be a riot why
you the thought of allowing these Brands
into your school yeah to
like get kids like hooked on this style
of
food I had this feeling when uh I think
we had a brief conversation about this
on an RV trip but I remember thinking
like those you want go to those
McDonald's parties as a kid I feel like
man I think McDonald's is such a good
job on influencing me to like McDonald's
my entire life absolutely talking about
yeah like you everyone would have
McDonald's parties and it was like a
treat when you get to go and it's like
they they're such a good way of like
dude the McDonald's ice SL I feel like
there's a I have this like deep like
calling that I just like McDonald's a
lot and and I don't feel like I it's
because I was like wow this is really
tasty and I just feel like it's a thing
that I've always liked yeah and it's a
constant that I it's always been in like
the recesses of your and I feel like
that's how you get like lifelong
customers is by putting [__] Jimmy
Johns in school and then getting them
onto it yeah making a profit Domino's
and Subway was our twos that but there
was two different food courts there was
the food court which had like the slop
that they put on the the thing and you
ordered it there was an olart section
yeah and then like a a different food
court that had pizza and Subway
sandwiches it's crazy so who would ever
go to the slop section um actually a
fair amount of people because Prett
expensive right it's about the same
right cuz you get the pizza by the slice
or you get like a $5 Subway sandwich but
the interesting thing about the food
court is you ended up over four years of
high school getting your favorite like
oh man the mozzarella sticks are great
also I like the cheeseburgers over here
because they taste this way sounds so
unhealthy already I mean it's American
school system what do you expect it's uh
it's how we do things but yeah I'm I'm
trying to think of like when I started
to like stuff like you know McDonald's
Pizza Huts and things like that and I'm
like would I have liked it if I didn't
have it as a kid and I think I still
would I don't know I there I'm sure
there's something still like but I feel
like it's definitely solidified my my
love for this because McDonald's has
that taste y it's a very distinct taste
and I feel like I've been hooked on that
since I was a kid it's weird that we
have cravings for McDonald's yeah I get
cravings for McDonald's that's unhealthy
yeah bro I'm loving it I'm loving it
there you go so I mean yeah I do feel
like it's hacked some part of my brain
well it used to be a reward like you
didn't nowadays you eat fast food all
the time but I remember when we grew up
it was kind of like once every two or 3
weeks or after like a dentist you'd go
get a milkshake or something but now
it's uh a lot of people just eat it
every day well I have a lot of
people Mission yeah pretty bad I don't I
think it was like the fries that hooked
me on McDonald's oh fries are good like
there's something on the menu that I
think everyone has a craving for in
something about the fries where you know
no matter what McDonald's fries were
always be a staple no matter where I go
in the world of something that I will
crave um it's the Big Mac for and it's
not your big I like the the spicy
chicken one spicy chicken spicy chicken
that one is also good so good in in
Japan you got to get it they try to dble
down spicy beef and I'm like it ain't
the same no no it's not very good damn
I'm glad you yeah we we we shared a
mutual love of the spicy chicken I think
we've ever SED for a [__] false as
much as we have now see now we're like
in high school again if I'm sure if I
had [__] Jimmy John's at school I'd
be like Jimmy is [__] good at though
jimm is good I shouldn't get hooked on
it as a kid yeah I should I should be
forced to eat [__] like broccoli but
okay if were you forced to eat [__] like
broccoli yes surely that should have
conditioned you to like it though right
but no actually like some of wait no yes
I like broccoli I love broccoli you love
broccoli I because I was forced to eat
it and get familiar with it As I Grew
Older I then became slowly over time
like oh I kind of like this thing now
and I feel like that's how a lot of why
I can't enjoy a lot of Japanese Foods
because I wasn't forced to eat them
growing up like Nat is kind of tough for
me cuz I never had anything like that
smell or Texture I feel like there is an
element of that to it uh but I also feel
like I don't know maybe children just
have different palettes as well of
course they do but change CH there are
so many things that I hated as a kid and
you know um I kind of every time I ate
it like no matter how much my parents
tried to force me i' would be like no I
don't want to [__] eat this you know
and then I swear if you eat something
though a lot growing up you will
gradually become more used to it unless
you're really like traumatized or
scarred by like tequila
yeah well alcohol that does yeah I mean
I I got like no one should be ingesting
that I got traumatized out of ever
eating [__] brussel sprouts for like
so many years uh and now I [__] love
them and you know had a period of my
life same with uh cauliflower I I like I
I ate a lot of cauliflower as a kid and
that like meant that when I was a young
adult I just like I can choose not to
eat cauliflower anymore and now I think
it tastes [__] great C the right way
you know so I don't know maybe it's a
pallet thing as well maybe
maybe I don't know but there L there are
a lot of kids who like grow up not
eating like certain things and that just
like persists for the rest of their life
and there's no explanation to it yeah
it's wild I think it's just it's a
mindset yeah and I think it is a mindset
yeah maybe also I think I went too far
like when we're young your parents say
you know when you're older you can eat
cookies in bed all right and then when I
got older I did
endlessly and then I got don't mind if I
good story c i overindulged on the
freedom and then it kind of went past
the Tipping Point back around where I'm
like I like eggplant and and spinach and
call I feel like you you have to
overindulge though at some point in your
life so that you're like man I I I know
how it feels to overindulge and I'll go
back when you're a kid when you UL you
don't you're like this is the best thing
ever yeah but as like a young adult you
know you have a a night where you're
just eating like three packets of chips
and and a DI the next morning you're
just like oh God I shouldn't have done
that you just described last night for
me but thank you I appreciate it yes but
yeah that's right part of the charm was
being told you couldn't do that so
you're like but now it just makes me
want to but what if I want ice cream for
breakfast that sounds incredible and
then you do it once you do it and you're
like oh this is
bad disgusting I'm shating myself at 10
in the
morning